so far they have been talking about
rearrangements in unique emotional
genomes but of course mammalian genomes
are multi chromosomes and we now want to
look at more complex scenarios of
rearrangements in multi chromosomal
genomes you may be surprised that we are
moving to seemingly more difficult case
without even a clue on how we would
address a simple case of sorting by
reversal in the case of unique Ramanujan
but as we you will see it turn out that
rearrangements of multi car maternal
genome I actually
counter-intuitively is a simple problem
we'll start from some example of
rearrangements in human genomes and
we'll talk about Philadelphia grammars
so these are normal chromosomes 9 and 22
in human and they have genes called ABL
and BC are located at this ramus now
consider a break in two places on the
one on each of this chromosome that
separate each Rama somes into two this
is not a like two breaks that reversals
do but in this case these two breaks I
applied two different chromosomes and
then afterwards can see the gluing these
segments in a new order resulting in you
chimeric chromosomes as a result
something happened genes ABL and BC are
that relocated a different chromosome in
normal human genomes and allocated at
the same chromosome next to each other
and as a result it destroys regulation
of these genes and lead to disease
called chronic myeloid leukemia or CML
it's actually this fusion honking uncle
genic fusion gene is a hallmark of CML
so from a computational perspective the
operations that I just show
would you is called translocation and it
exchange segments of different
chromosomes between each other and
thousands of different rearrangements
and many translocations are known for
different tumors knowledge both these
rearrangements is very important for
studies of cancer in particular the ABL
BCR fusion genes in a CML since
biologists knew how it looks like it
enabled development of a very efficient
cancer drug called Gleevec and so far I
showed you an example when a single
rearrangement leads to a disease in
reality for many humour tumors the
situation is more complex here I showed
you an image a resulting from a
technique called Ramazan painting and as
a result of this Ramazan painting every
harm us nor chromosome in normal cell
should be painted by single color there
is unique color for every normal human
hands however if you start
Ramazan painting on tumor genome and in
this case this is mcf7 human breast
cancer cell line that you see a very
colorful pictures this colorful picture
illustrates that hardly any ramazan
remain intact in mcf7 since every
Harmison consists of different pieces
sometimes 2 3 even 4 pieces of different
human chromosome combined together and
it's a very difficult question to figure
out what sequence of rearrangements has
produced the mcf7 tumor genomes and we
will in the next section we will look at
operation on multi chromosomal genomes
that include not only translocations but
also
fusions and visions for example fusion
simply combine two chromosomes glue them
together and fission break a muscle into
two for example humans have 23
chromosomes but chimpanzee around
Gutenberg and gorillas have 24
chromosomes because few million years
ago two chromosomes in human chimpanzee
ancestors will fuse together into a
single chromosome in human and in the
next section we will look at the
algorithmic problem that is called the
to break distance to address the
question of how to find rearrangements
in multi chromosomal shifts